et aujourd'hui pendant que vous tourniez
le clip de votre tube syrie dont on a
décidé de mettre la chanson à fond dans
la somme sauf dans l'ascenseur de h2o
beaucoup trop fort en goût du non-stop
pendant cinq heures impossible de
l'arrêter en début de journée regarder
trop qui se rattache 2
c'est bon
mais comme n'importe quel morceau plus
les heures passent plus les visages se
sert je vois que lors les joueurs et
leur continue de tourner au bout d'un
moment tout le monde et pour l'espagne
au liban se passe chez nous et comme la
musique était un sound stuff
tout le monde se renvoie l'ascenseur
parce que même quand il a l'art et les
gens entendent la musique vous allez
voir tout le monde pascal matinée à se
renvoyer la personne pour je ne ferai
pas
[Applaudissements]
ah bon c'est ce match
on a vu notre ami nourdine qui est au
bout du rouleau à 13h quand même on l'a
laissé pendant sept heures en la force
de charbon un bloc beau jeu dont le
grand jeu des tartes on l'a fait
quelques fois j'étais obligé de le faire
quand même une dernière fois on a
prétendu aux gens de la société de
comptes vais faire des nouveaux badges
et qu'il fallait une reconnaissance
faciale pour imprimer ce nouveau badge
regardez le dispositif c'est un des plus
réussis qu'on ait fait à will haven
écran un objectif un clavier et sous le
clavier
bien sûr vous allez le voir la tarte à
partir de là tout s'enchaîne très vite
ans
veillée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là bas il fait du tout